stillhalten oder lockern das ist und
bleibt die große frage
auch heute bei der regierungserklärung
der kanzlerin
wann kommen wieder wieder raus und was
sind die kriterien dafür der shutdown
geht ans markt trotz erster lockerungen
und die kanzlerin mahnt zur geduld
lassen sie uns jetzt das erreichte nicht
verspielen und ein rückschlag christine
es wäre jammerschade wenn uns die
voreilige hoffnung am ende bestraft
bleiben wir alle auf dem weg in die
nächste phase der pandemie klug und
vorsichtig es ist eine mahnung nicht zu
früh zu lockern denn die disziplin lässt
nach in rheinland pfalz etwa darf ein
outlet center wieder öffnen
in zweibrücken an der grenze zum
saarland die einzelnen geschäfte seien
schließlich klein genug über öffnungs
diskussions orgien soll merkel sich
intern beschwert haben
ich sage ihnen ich trage die beschlüsse
die bund und länder am mittwoch letzter
woche getroffen haben aus voller
überzeugung mit doch ihre umsetzung
seither bereitet mir sorgen
sie wirkt auf mich in teilen der vor um
nicht zu sagen zuvor auch experten
warnen davor den vorsprung nicht zu
verspielen wenn man die maßnahmen
komplett lockert und wenn alle anfangen
sich die eigenen
interpretationsspielräume auszulegen
ganz frei dann starten an vielen orten
in deutschland plötzlich neue
infektionsketten
es bleibt eine geduldsprobe offen ob das
land sie besteht malu dreyer
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
die kanzlerin soll sich auf einer
präsidiumssitzung ausgerechnet über
irland geärgert haben weil ein
outlet-center schon öffnete gehören sie
zu denen die zu forschen
ich bin nicht der auffassung dass wir zu
forsch sind sondern gesetzen eigentlich
die beschlüsse genau oben die wir
gemeinsam miteinander besprochen haben
und das outlet center ist so geöffnet
wie wir es gesagt haben nämlich dass wir
nicht über 800 quadratmeter geht sondern
dass die läden die ihr einzel vermietet
sind genau die jene voraussetzungen auch
erfüllen und in dem center an sich
dürfen ja keine veranstaltungen
stattfinden
es gibt auch gar keinen unterschied
zwischen ganz ganz vielen bundesländern
ob jetzt das main taunus sender auf hat
oder ob baden württemberg machen
entscheidung des gerichts oder der
anderes gericht
hier ist ebenfalls die 800 quadratmeter
regelung aus legt wie eben auch
rheinland pfalz das zeigt einfach nur
dass die beschlüsse die getroffen worden
sind in unserer verantwortung juristisch
sauber umgesetzt werden müssen und ich
sage auch noch mal sehr sehr klar es
gibt gar keinen grund auf freiland fall
zu deuten wir handeln mit größter
sorgfalt mit ganz großer verantwortung
und verantwortungsbewusstsein und ich
fühle mich nicht angesprochen an dieser
stelle mit der vorschreibt weil wir
genau das tun dass wir miteinander
gesprochen haben
cem özdemir ist bei uns von bündnis 90
die grünen herrschte mir auch ihre
partei fordert eine ausweitung der not
betreuung der kinder sie sagen gerade an
die familien und an die kinder wurde zu
wenig gedacht da gibt's blinde flecken
feiern also auch bündnis 90 die grünen
öffnungs diskussions orgien nein ganz
sicher nicht das was wir erreicht haben
das haben wir als gesellschaft gemeinsam
erreicht großen opfern denken sie an die
arbeitsplätze denken sie an insbesondere
die kleinen mittelständler betriebe
denken sie aber auch die ganzen familien
zu hause mit den kindern und das darf
man jetzt nicht gefährden insofern hat
die kanzlerin recht mit ihrer mahnung
man muss immer auf dem stand der
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse prüfen
welcher nächste schritt erfolgen kann
wir haben es gemeinsam gemacht bund und
länder das sind alle demokratischen
parteien beteiligt und so sollten wir
das weiterhin machen ihn so verteidigt
die kritik der kanzlerin dass die länder
das trifft glaube ich weniger auf
rheinland pfalz zu ich denke da eher so
an den wettbewerb den es bei der cdu
gerade gibt um die frage wer wird frau
merkel nachfolgender sind manche ein
bisschen zu nassforsch unterwegs das
brauchen wir jetzt wirklich nicht was
meine partei in meine fraktion sagt das
ist mir müssen zum beispiel gucken dass
wir neben der notbetreuung auch
diejenigen denken sie an der leine
ziehen dann denkt sie an die kinder die
aus benachteiligten familien kommen dass
die nicht abgehängt werden überall da wo
man es verantworten kann
schritt für schritt weiter gehen aber
bitte nicht pauschal um das alles zu
gefährden was wir mühsam erreicht haben
herbert dies ist bei uns
vorstandsvorsitzender von vwr dies sie
fahren jetzt in teilen die produktion
wieder hoch nach sechs wochen stillstand
die autohäuser sind auch wieder auf wie
sicher sind sie sich eigentlich ganz
persönlich gefragt dass das nicht geht
und wir haben uns sehr gut vorbereitet
wir haben in den fertigungen masken wir
haben die fertigungsprozesse umgestellt
deutlich unsere religion maßnahmen
gesteuert
wir starten mit schicht and kopplungen
so dass wir weniger leute haben etwa die
hälfte der indirekten arbeitet weiterhin
von zu hause also ich glaube wir machen
sehr konsequent maßnahmen auch in den
autohäusern haben wir organisiert dass
autos übergeben werden können ohne
persönlichen kontakt alle sind sehr gut
vorbereitet
nun steckt die automobilindustrie
ohnehin in einer umbruchphase und jetzt
kommt's corona noch oben drauf so sieht
es bei vw aus
lieferengpässe absatzeinbrüche vw
daimler und co meldeten kurzarbeit an
allein bei volkswagen für rund 80.000
beschäftigte in deutschland
unser gast vw-chef dies sagt corona
koste sein unternehmen rund zwei
milliarden euro pro woche
jetzt soll es wieder losgehen langsam
und auf abstand fährt vw die produktion
wieder an
1 100 punkte plan soll für sicherheit
sorgen
es gelten strenge hygiene regeln wo
abstand halten nicht geht ist maske
pflicht den shot down überwinden
doch der wirtschaftliche schaden bleibt
vw ruft deshalb nach staatlichen
kaufprämien auch für verbrenner 1 2
milliarden pro woche ist eine menge holz
hätten sie nicht trotzdem noch drei oder
vier wochen durchhalten kann
ja sicher können nur noch zwei drei
wochen durchhalten oder auch 4
das nicht die frage aber ich glaube für
die für unsere gesellschaft wir haben
glaube ich die krise bisher sehr gut
bewältigt sehr diszipliniert und ich
glaube es auch eine tolle leistung für
unsere gesellschaft aber jetzt geht es
darum das system wieder in gang zu
bringen die wirtschaft wieder in schwung
zu bekommen weil die liebe lernen können
was natürlich nicht durchhalten und das
gilt für manche branchen noch mehr als
für uns denken sie an die gastronomie
denken sie an die tourismus branche aber
wir sehen china läuft uns voraus wir uns
vier bis sechs wochen und wir sehen dass
dort ist eben schon gelingt gleichzeitig
die wirtschaft wieder in gang zu bringen
einhalten striktes der hygienemaßnahmen
den virus unter kontrolle zu halten aber
dennoch die wirtschaftliche öffnung zu
bringen bevor das glaube ich ist der
wichtigste teil oder der nächste
wichtige teil der krisenbewältigung und
der ist gegebenenfalls schwieriger als
der harte lockt dann freue mich jetzt in
frankfurt main ihren kind zu begrüßen
sie ist ich muss noch die richtige
kamera suchen und da ist die sie ist
wissenschaftsjournalistin promovierte
chemikerin moderatoren wie jetzt haben
wissenschaftler von vielen institutionen
gesagt ein paar wochen mehr stillstand
könnten hält
dieses virus auszutrocknen das ist
wahrscheinlich das ideal und es ist
einfach politisch nicht durchsetzbar
ob es politisch nicht durchsetzbar ist
das ist die wichtige politische
entscheidung aber aus wissenschaftlicher
sicht ist das deswegen ideal nicht weil
es die rein medizinische sicht ist
sondern eben weil es nicht nur die
menschen leben mit mit einrechnet
sondern auch die wirtschaft auch die
gesellschaft auch unser sozialleben denn
wenn wir jetzt noch ein paar wochen
durchhalten könnten und die fallzahlen
auch weiter senken könnten dann
verschaffen wir uns damit freiheiten bis
zum ende dieser epidemie denn die dauer
der leider noch ein jahr oder länger
freiheiten auch für gesellschaft und
wirtschaft die wir sonst nicht hätten
also die wir nicht haben werden wenn wir
jetzt zu schnell locker lassen also das
ist ähnlich wie bei diesem experiment
mit den kindern und dem marsch - also wo
man ein kind ein marshmallow verspricht
wenn es das mal wieder sofort ist oder
zwei wenn es 15 minuten wartet und viele
kinder können nicht 15 minuten warten
und ich hoffe wir können das aber da ist
sofort erste plädoyer und ein sehr
schönes bild
jetzt ist natürlich die frage nach dem
paradoxon in dem wir leben ist die lage
deshalb so bedrohlich weil immer mehr
menschen glauben dass es nicht mehr so
bedrohlich ist ja definitiv also wenn
wir jetzt anfangen zu argumentieren wir
müssen zum beispiel die wirtschaft
wieder zum laufen bringt wenn wir halten
das nicht mehr lange aus dann darf man
sich ja nicht vorstellen dass wir ab
jetzt graduell in eine normalität
reingehen und dann bis die epidemie
vorbei ist das durchhalten nein es wird
natürlich immer wieder die zahlen werden
wieder ansteigen es wird wie der neue
ausbrüche geben es wird dann auch
zwangsläufig neue lok downs geben müssen
und 1 müssen wir verstehen nur am anfang
der epidemie oder je weiter er je früher
wir dran sind in der epidemie desto
leichter ist es
ausbrüche zu verlangsamen oder
einzudämmen
die sind jetzt ganz am anfang und wir
sehen dass uns der aktuelle lotto und
bereits in unsere grenzen bringt denn
wir das nochmal haben später im jahr
dann wären die schäden viel größer seien
auch für die wirtschaft zum beispiel bei
uns ist professor hendrik streek
virologe direktor des uniklinikums in
bonn und erfinder der heinsberg studie
er streckt die folgen dieser erste
lockerungen dieser ersten vorsichtigen
lockerungen werden wir erst in zehn
tagen abschätzen können weshalb die
politik sich auch diesen zeitraum
gegönnt hat das erstmal abzuwarten
werden wir dann auch wissen welche
dieser maßnahmen falsch waren wo wir um
die kanzlerin zu zitieren zu forsch an
ja das ist ja ein bisschen das problem
von solchen infektionen dass wir nicht
sofort die ergebnisse sehen von
irgendwelchen maßnahmen also das virus
nimmt sich die eigene zeit in den
infektionsketten und auch dass wir das
merklich wahrnehmen
wir haben einen sehr schnellen lockdown
gemacht und ohne nachvollziehen zu
können welcher schritt eigentlich zu was
geführt hat und das kann man auch an den
kurven jetzt gar nicht ablesen
jetzt ist die hoffnung zumindest
virologisch das marktwirtschaftlich
anderssein und politisch anders gewollt
seien aber biologisch dass man sich
anschaut schritt für schritt was die
lockerung bringen und wo ist zu vieles
und wo es zu wenig ist jetzt ist ja der
ort sehr entscheidend das sagen nicht
nur sie das sagt man sich auch selber zu
viele menschen auf engem raum ist
wirklich ungünstig egal ob jetzt im
öffentlichen raum oder auch in einem
büro wann ist es zu viel wissen wir dass
schon das kann man gar nicht wirklich
gut sagen also wir aber was wir gesehen
haben während dieser pandemie weltweit
ist das wenn viele menschen an einem
raum gemeinsam eng beieinander gefeiert
haben und engt versammelt gewesen sind
dann haben wir die großen ausbrüche
gehabt das ist in südkorea gewesen dass
es in ischgl in gangelt in der trompete
das waren eben diese großen ausbruchs
ereignisse wo wir auch sehen dass dort
eigentlich die schweren fälle und auch
die todesfälle eigentlich in diesem
zusammenhang mehr standen als die
ausbrüche die also oder die
infektionsketten wie im nachhinein
entstanden sind
nun hat es in dieser woche um exakt
diese kurve aus dem robert koch institut
eine heftige diskussion gegeben
die berühmte reproduktions zahl man
sieht dass sie im grunde schon vor dem
lock down also vor diesem 23
st der neunte dritte war der tag an dem
die regierung festlegte dass große
veranstaltungen zu untersagen sind der
sechzehnte dritte war dann diese bund
länder entscheidung
und man sieht dass sich das verhalten
der menschen schon vor dem lockdown
verändert hat und auch da schon bei 1
und unter 1 lag frage an wie war der
lock down also übertrieben wir jetzt
einige behaupten ja wenn man sich diese
kurve anschaut dann ist es tatsächlich
naheliegend daraus zu folgern dass der
doktor nichts gebracht hat denn
eigentlich so wird man meinen müsste man
ja ab den doktor sehen dass die kurve
noch noch weiter runter geht
das stimmt aber so nicht dafür gibt es
verschiedene gründe ich würmer 2 nennen
eine sache ist also die reproduktion
zahl ist ja einer sagt uns ja zum einen
wie viele menschen ein infizierter
ansteckt sie sagt uns auch gleichzeitig
die infektionszahlen steigen gleich
bleiben oder sinken also ob die eher
zahl größer gleich oder unter 1 ist
jetzt wurden wir im märz auch schon
vorgewarnt dass es wurde vorausgesagt
zum beispiel auch vom rk ii iv recht
haben dass man sich einfach vergessen
die haben gesagt leute passt auf wir
werden sehen die infektionszahlen deren
steigende nächster zeit obwohl wird die
maßnahmen wo wir strenge maßnahmen jetzt
eingeführt haben keine panik das heißt
nicht dass unsere massnahmen nicht
wirken sondern unsere test kapazitäten
werden gerade ausgebaut
das heißt wenn man mehr testen kann sehr
klar werden wir auch mehr infizierte
entdecken und so steigen die
infektionszahlen das ist da
mit drin trotzdem sehen wir eben dass
wir so ein bisschen uns bei 1 1
gedümpelt haben daraus folge ich jetzt
dass unsere maßnahmen durchaus wirken ja
um so was zum beispiel zu kompensieren
die zweite sache ist es ganz interessant
wenn man sich mal die mobilitäts daten
von uns anschaut also vereinfacht gesagt
wie viel wir uns bewegen dann sieht man
dass wir uns tatsächlich vor dem
offiziellen von der offiziellen kontakt
schwere selbst isoliert haben aus angst
also wir waren eine art schockstarre die
mobilitäts daten gehen runter das war
auch ein 1 monat bei dem also im märz
werden die ersten gruner toten
wir hatten die bilder aus italien
gewährten den börsencrash das heißt wir
haben uns gewissermaßen haben wir den
locker und freiwillig früher angefangen
als er offiziell gestartet wurde
man hat aber dann auch gesehen dass die
mobilitäts daten wieder hochgehen
woraus man eine gewisse entspanntheit
auch wieder raus lesen kann ich denke
wir kennen das wahrscheinlich alle also
ich glaube sie haben es alle so ein
bisschen an die situation gewöhnt und
auch trotz der wieder erhöhten mobilität
also die steigt langsam an bleibt die
ärzte ungefähr gleich auch daraus können
wir jetzt wieder schließen dass die
maßnahmen wirken dass sie den das
kompensiert haben nur also das
vielleicht noch als letzte anmerkung wir
wissen bisher sicher dass das
maßnahmenpaket so wie wir es hatten also
schulschließung geschäftsschließungen
die hygienemaßnahmen alles zusammen dass
das wirkt natürlich wollen wir jetzt
trotzdem irgendwie aus diesem lock down
raus ja weil der lockout nicht nur sehr
belastend der ist natürlich auch
überhaupt nicht zielgerichtet das ist
jetzt eine maßnahme die wir treffen
müssen aber natürlich hätten wir lieber
zielgerichtete maßnahmen die genauso
wirksam sind uns aber mehr freiheit
geben also deswegen finde ich es richtig
darüber nachzudenken wie
können wir intelligent und vorsichtig
hier raus ohne uns alles wieder kaputt
zu machen aber nicht weil wir glauben
dass bringt eh nichts sondern weil wir
das nicht mehr lange aushalten das ist
ein wichtiger unterschied
und dann sind wir bei der frage an herrn
streik nicht nur die kanzlerin sondern
auch viele ihrer kollegen waren
natürlich davor dass das
infektionsgeschehen im grunde wieder
außer kontrolle geraten könnte ist diese
furcht unbegründet in ihren augen
nein natürlich ist das nicht unbegründet
und es kann sein dass hier mit einer in
der zweiten in eine zweite oder dritte
infektionsfälle haben werden aber ich
glaube diese annahmen verkennen ein paar
dinge die wir gelernt haben über das
virus also rein die fakten dabei dass
zum beispiel die großen einmal was wir
schon angesprochen haben die großen
infektions ereignisse waren immer solche
veranstaltungen gewesen
wir haben nicht die todeswelle gehabt
über ostern wir haben nicht die
kapazitätsgrenze unser krankenhäuser
überschritten
und wir haben wir haben alle einen
crashkurs in hygiene gehabt wir haben
alle gelernt was die das virus
übertragen wird und wie man sich davor
schützt und ich wir müssen anfangen mit
dem virus zu leben das kennt weder
grenzen das kennt keine
keine stoppschilder sondern wir werden
damit leben müssen die wir mit allen
anderen vier in de mission coronaviren
zurzeit leben die bei uns immer wieder
im winter probleme machen ich denke auch
wir werden einen sommer effekt haben das
wird immer noch diskutiert aber ob es
wirklich einen effekt gibt aber es gibt
sehr interessante studien von mrt dazu
die das auch suggerieren
auch ein blick nach australien reicht um
das annehmen zu können
aber wir um die infektion und die
schweren infektionen kontrollieren zu
können müssen wir auch die infektions
dosis kontrollieren können also wieviel
virus man abgerückt und das machen wir
über hygiene und das machen wir vor
allem über den sommer und daher gehe ich
nicht eigentlich selber davon aus dass
hier eine zweite welle bekommen würden
außer wir fahren jetzt ganz runter und
dann kriegen wir eine zweite verändert
das kann genauso passieren aber ich weiß
es genau so wenig wie jeder andere der
eine modellrechnung dürfen
nun hat sich frau dreyer interessant die
politik ja offensichtlich gegen diese
theologische und nicht nur biologische
sondern gegen die schule entschieden das
virus auszutrocknen und eben noch zwei
oder drei wochen weiter zu machen warum
eigentlich näher zum einen gibt es sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen unter den
virologen und zum anderen sind wir davon
überzeugt dass wir eigentlich in
deutschland zusammen sehr sehr viel
erreicht haben
und es hat was mit der großen disziplin
und der verantwortungsbewusstseins der
bevölkerung zu tun
aber natürlich auch mit dem politischen
entscheidungen die wir in deutschland
die länder und der bund gemeinsam sehr
konsequent auch durchführen und wir
glauben auch dass es richtig ist schritt
für schritt zu kleinen lockerungen zu
kommen natürlich immer mit dem
vorzeichen dass man schauen muss wie
entwickelt sich die infektions kurve
denn das oberste ziel bleibt natürlich
immer noch dass wir den
gesundheitsschutz tatsächlich am besten
gewährleisten wollen den der bevölkerung
gegenüber
dennoch glaube ich ist es sinnvoll denn
man muss ja sehen was macht dieser
lockdown auch mit einer
l schafft das können wir auch nicht
ignorieren mit der wirtschaft einerseits
aber natürlich auch mit den sozialen
gegebenheiten mit der belastung in
familien all das was wir kennen aus dem
alltag
ich glaube es ist verantwortungsvoll
dennoch es ist schon klar man muss
bürgern bürgerinnen auch immer wieder
erklären die zahlen gehen runter und
trotzdem dürfen wir nicht vertrauen wir
müssen immer ein bisschen bösgläubig
glauben und es bleiben und deshalb denke
ich ist das allerwichtigste dass man mit
maßen in kleinen schritten tatsächlich
solar erleichterungen kommt dass man
genau beobachtet ist die infektion
überhaupt noch kontrollierbar dass wir
echt nicht mehr zu seinem ausbruch
kommen und das dritte ist das sind für
mich einfach die drei goldenen regeln
das ist die hygiene das ist der abstand
das ist die maske der mut nasenschutz
und daran müssen wir uns alle gewöhnen
bei jeder lockerung die wir tun dass wir
einfach in einer welches gerade leben
die anders geprägt ist als es in der
vergangenheit war
solange dieses virus eben nicht in mit
einem impfstoff oder mit einem guten
medikament haben auch entsprechend
bekämpft werden kann wenn wir auf jeden
fall noch diskutieren frage nach
frankfurt zu
nun hat man als bürger natürlich
trotzdem ein wenig verunsicherung im
herzen erst stand diese verdopplung zahl
im zentrum
jetzt war es dann die produktionszahl
das haben sie uns auch gerade noch mal
schön erklärt versteht der bürger
eigentlich was unser ziel ist und wie
wir das erreichen
ja das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
verwirrend das kann ich auch gut
nachvollziehen denn wir waren uns vor
paar wochen einig ja wir haben zum
beispiel die bilder aus italien oder
spanien gesehen und haben gesagt das
darf hier nicht passieren wir können
nicht zulassen dass wir mehr
intensivpatienten als intensivbetten
haben es darf nicht passieren dass man
entscheidungen darüber treffen muss wer
kriegt jetzt eine lebensrettende
behandlung und wo er nicht und da war
die bereitschaft auch sehr groß und da
war da war auch die angst glaube ich
noch recht groß
jetzt haben wir ja das ziel erstmal
erreicht und dann fragt man sich
natürlich warum haben sind wir jetzt
überhaupt noch in diesem schrecklichen
lockdown und da es ist ganz wichtig das
ziel nicht nur qualitativ zu sehen
sondern auch quantitativ denn wir haben
das ziel recht knapp gerade erreicht
also bildlich gesprochen haben uns jetzt
ein bisschen luft verschafft aber das
wasser steht uns bis kurz unter die
nasenspitze man darf sich jetzt nicht
irritieren darf sich nicht täuschen
lassen von leeren betten auf
intensivstationen denn eines hat sich
nicht geändert
es scheinen wir gerade zu vergessen das
virus hat immer noch ein exponentielles
wachstum das bedeutet diese betten
können sich sehr schnell wieder füllen
schneller als wir es unter kontrolle
kriegen können gerade wegen immer diesen
verkehr weg wir können erst in zwei oder
drei wochen schließen szenen in die
vergangenheit zurückschauen bis dann
kann es schon wieder zu spät gewesen
sein
und deswegen ist es ganz wichtig zu
sagen da muss ich auch zum beispiel
professor strikt widersprechen wenn er
sagt wir müssen mit dem virus leben
wir müssen mit dem virus leben wenn wir
es nicht schaffen die infektionszahlen
jetzt noch weiter zu senken und ich
denke der zug ist noch nicht abgefahren
wir können wir sollten es unbedingt
versuchen denn mit dem virus leben heißt
dass wir bis zum ende dieser epidemien
weil noch immer das sein wird in einem
jahr oder länger heißt es unter immer
wieder strecken maßnahmen zur inter
starken einschränkungen zu leben immer
wieder ausbrüche zu haben immer wieder
nachjustieren zu müssen und bestimmt
auch vielleicht strengere lockdown zu
haben als jetzt und ich finde es auch zu
früh zu sagen dass die hygienemaßnahmen
das sind was uns jetzt retten wird denn
man kann ja nicht einerseits sagen wir
wissen momentan noch nicht welches
maßnahmenpaket das richtige ist das
finden wir gerade heraus und
gleichzeitig aber sagen ja die die
hygiene die ist es das reicht schon
da das ist jetzt noch zu früh ich würde
mich freuen wenn es so ist denn wir mit
hygienemaßnahmen alleine auskommen aber
wir dürfen jetzt wenn wir jetzt nur 1 cm
in die falsche richtung machen kann man
direkt mehrere
peter ausrutschen das bedeutet
exponentielles wachstum das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen sind wir strikt schon
raus aus einer solchen gefahr wie sie
beschreibt oder sagen sie sie sehen eben
tatsächlich eine chance dass wir mehr
lockert dass wir uns mehr trauen also
meine als facharzt für virologie hat man
ja sehr viel und infektionsepidemiologie
sehr viel mit tieren zu tun und auch
sehr viel mit coronaviren da gibt es
nicht nur das saas sowie zwei oder saas
hq 143 alles namen die man gar nicht
wissen will
und die sind bei uns heimisch und es ist
ein aberglaube zu glauben dass man an
deutschland eine grenze zieht und was in
belgien oder österreich passiert und
dort vielleicht kein mehr virus hat dass
es nicht in deutschland über die grenze
kommen wird wie deutschland sich verhält
ist eine sache das mag uns eine pause
geben aber das virus ist weltweit
heimisch geworden wir werden es aus dem
menschlichen körper in der welt nicht
mehr raus kriegen und daher ist es etwas
womit wir leben müssen und unsere
gesellschaft anfangen muss damit zu
leben wir haben auch gelernt mit diesen
anderen coronaviren zu lernen ich glaube
leben ich glaube das letzte war vor 600
jahren oder so wurde das so ne welle x
gekommen ist das ein corona virus sich
bei uns verbreitet hat und endemisch
geworden ist legen sie mich nicht auf
diese zahl 40 mal in das waren 600 jahre
aber ist breite moment auf ein wissendes
immunsystem und über die zeit werden wir
anfangen damit umgehen zu können und wir
müssen es einfach lernen damit umzugehen
und daher glaube ich es in der
entscheidender faktor und das sagt auch
die gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene
die wirklich ein tolles paper dazu
geschrieben hat zeigt dass die hygiene
und die infektions dosis die man über
hygieneregeln reduziert wirklich eines
der besten mittel ist um so ein virus zu
kontrollieren aber das sind hygieniker
gefragt und gar nicht die viola ja wir
kommen auch darauf natürlich nochmal
zurück zum sc mir nicht nur für vw geht
natürlich dass der eine die
lockdown besser verkraften kann als der
andere
es trifft uns alle gleich aber es trifft
manche gleicher die frage ist ist der
leidensdruck bei den menschen die eben
nicht ein polster haben einfach auch
größer momentan und damit auch die
ungeduld ist doch erfreulich dass die
intensivbetten nicht genutzt werden
mussten in dem maße da kann man sich
auch mal drüber freuen
und jetzt kann man daraus die lehre
ziehen dass man sagt die maßnahmen waren
übertrieben
da kann es aber anders interpretieren
man sagen die maßnahmen haben gewirkt
gott sei dann brauchten wir das nicht
ich würde
zu letzterer interpretation raten und
dann die ganzen kollegen von mir jetzt
in der politik und anderswo die jetzt
sagen wieder alle kinder in die schule
und so weiter ich würde mir wünschen
dass die einen wettbewerb machen wer
denn die besten schulen hat mit den
saubersten kloß mit seifen überall auf
dem klo und vielleicht auch im
unterricht die reinigungs geschichten
dass wir das auch wirklich ins fleisch
und blut übergeht es würde ich mir
wünschen dass sie sich da mal ihren
mütchen kühlen wo das thema
digitalisierung in der schule das sage
ich als zweifacher vater
da können sich gerne mütchen kühlen aber
das problem ist doch wenn die foto nach
vorne sagen das ist alles nicht so
schlimm
wir können jetzt wieder die zügel locker
lassen was macht das mit dem rest der
gesellschaft wir sehen doch die bilder
auf den straßen
also wie soll man die leute
disziplinieren dass wir weiterhin
einschränkungen akzeptieren ich bin ganz
bei ihnen das was sie über die hygiene
sagen das ist doch was das hätte auch
schon vorher gelten müssen stehen sie
endlich das erste mal habe ich gehört
von dem niesen in die armbeuge
als mein sohn damals im kindergarten das
von der erzieherin gelernt wird und uns
erwachsene ermahnt hat wir soll es bitte
auch so machen dass du hast mir gerne
beibehalten dass wir uns immer die hände
waschen vielleicht etwas weniger die
hände schütteln das durch vor bitteschön
auch nach profit 19 beibehalten
zu dem argument recht sich trotzdem noch
mal zu dem argument dass wir selbst in
der hochphase wo dieser berühmtere
produktionsfaktor noch eins zu drei war
nicht an die grenzen unseres
gesundheitssystems gekommen sind ist es
in ihren augen nicht eigentlich weiß was
uns sicher oder sicher machen sollte ich
bin ganz und gar bei herz mehr das ist
eine hochleistung gewesen unseres
gesundheitssystems
und man kann einfach nur sagen auch
politiker da die weichen genau richtig
gestellt und wir können einfach nur froh
sein dass diese betten nicht alle
genutzt werden mussten nach wie vor bin
ich der auffassung dass wir in
deutschland eines der besten
gesundheitssysteme der welt haben und es
ist richtig und wichtig dass wir auch in
zukunft intensiv kapazitäten haben auf
die wir auch jederzeit zurückgreifen
können klar wir müssen auch darauf
schauen was ist mit den ganzen elektiven
leistungen die verschoben worden sind
und kann man vielleicht auch an dem
system noch mal den ein oder anderen
punkt etwas regulieren damit nicht allzu
viele ob es dann auch dauerhaft oder
längerfristig verschoben werden aber ich
rate uns trotz allem immer eine wirklich
sehr sehr gute reserve zu haben und auch
innerhalb kürzester zeit noch weitere
betten mobilisieren zu können denn eines
darf uns wirklich nicht passieren wenn
wir irgendwo ein infektionsherd haben
und es muss ja gar nicht in ganz
deutschland seien es kann auch eine an
einer stelle sein dass wir dann ganz
ganz sicher stellen können dass jeder
mensch in unserem land wirklich sehr
sehr gut behandelt wird und das hat das
gesundheitssystem bis jetzt wirklich ist
sehr gut gezeigt und ich bin froh dass
es so ist und gucken wir noch einmal auf
die wirtschaft handys sie sind relativ
zügig auf kurzarbeit gegangen
das haben die mitarbeiter auch teuer
bezahlt weil sie mit 67 prozent ihres
gehaltes leben müssen
sie haben jetzt gefordert dass eine
kaufprämie geben soll
also auch da unterstützung durch den
staat und durch die bürger machen sie
das alles irgendwie aus interesse an der
allgemeinheit oder da tun so wir haben
glaube ich schon auf beiträge geleistet
wir haben für 40 millionen zb
medizinische ausrüstung gespendet in
deutschland die bundesregierung
unterstützt beim einkauf 7 millionen
masken gebracht porsche hat gross
gespendet in spanien haben wir begonnen
zum beispiel beatmungs hilfen zu bauen
800 davon sind ausgeliefert also
unternehmen hat sich schon umgestellt
wirklich gesellschaftlich zu helfen da
müssen wir uns keinen vorwurf machen
auch ich würde es auch gern noch einmal
betone ich glaube wir können in
deutschland wirklich stolz darauf sein
auf das was wir erreicht haben gemeinsam
mit viel disziplin die
gesellschaft hat funktioniert und ich
glaube wir haben glück gehabt weil es
hat eben schon sein können dass wir mit
ein paar mehr infektionsherden paar mehr
partys vielleicht eben schon zuständig
gehabt hätten wie in italien wo wir sie
gesehen haben oder vielleicht auch in
spanien fast dramatisch waren wir haben
wir haben werke entspannt und von daher
glaube ich kann man bisher alles richtig
macht jetzt geht es darum die wirtschaft
in gang zu bringen weil die wirtschaft
wie das ist natürlich auf dauer auch
nicht
wir haben eigentlich eine situation
erreicht wo wir guten gewissens sehr
vorsichtig aber jetzt daran denken
müssen die wirtschaft wieder in gang zu
kurzer zeit zur kurzarbeit
wir haben natürlich sind wir in
kurzarbeit 60 prozent unsere mitarbeiter
volkswagen ist ein sehr sozial
eingestellt das unternehmen wir doppeln
auf auf 100 prozent also die mitarbeiter
bei uns haben keinen kaufkraftverlust
allerdings glaube ich ist es auch unser
gutes recht die die sozialkassen da ein
geflecht zunehmen wird zahlen das ja
bisher kein sind keine staatsgelder
sondern das ist im prinzip der beitrag
zu den sozialkassen
wir zahlen wir haben den letzten zehn
jahren über vier milliarden eingezahlt
zahlen pro jahr 500 millionen und haben
jetzt im märz bei volkswagen etwa 40
millionen unterstützung der usa
abgerufen das wird etwas mehr werden im
april aber ich glaube das kann man
vertreten
wir müssen und können natürlich nur über
diese lockerungen nachdenken wenn wir
die gefahren besser einschätzen können
und die studie die elektrik in gangelt
schrägstrich heinsberg gemacht hat
sollte genau dazu dienen sie ist jetzt
in ihrer finalen phase herr streik
begonnen haben sie im märz das schauen
wir uns nochmal an
wir benötigen einen fahrplan der uns den
weg in eine verantwortungsvolle
normalität zeigt für diesen fahrplan
hoffte die landesregierung auf daten aus
gangelt im kreis heinsberg eine studie
unseres gastes hendrik streik seit ende
märz wird dort untersucht wie sich nach
einer karnevalsfeier das virus
ausgebreitet hat und wie viele bewohner
sich infiziert haben ohne es zu wissen
es ist die erste studie in einem corona
hotspot zwischenergebnisse der gemeinde
gangelt und kreis heinsberg können wir
davon ausgehen dass 15 prozent der
bevölkerung derzeit eine immunität gegen
saas sowie zwei ausgebildet haben wir
haben zumindest zahlen die wirklich mut
machen und man sieht dann auch dass
maßnahmen greifen
doch es gibt kritik an stricks arbeit
wurde die zwischen studie überhastet
veröffentlicht fehlten teile zum
verständnis war hilfe einer pr-agentur
nötig der fahrplan der landesregierung
steht jedenfalls kurs auflockerung
ihre zwischenergebnisse ihre zwischen
studie trägt dienten als argument die
frage ist im raum werden sie und ihre
kollegen durch die landesregierung von
nordrhein-westfalen instrumentalisiert
haben sie sich instrumentalisieren
lassen nein gar nicht und ich wusste
auch nicht dass die studie also
vielleicht wissen sie mehr als ich aber
als instrument oder als argument galt
wir sind ja auch die landesregierung
zugegangen als erstes und haben an herrn
baumann und habe ihm vorgeschlagen dass
man so eine studie machen muss und dabei
sowohl her
lasseter ist auch laumann sehr schnell
dabei und haben das mit finanziert die
hauptfinanzierung kommt im übrigen von
den eigenen instituts mitteln von
verschiedenen institutionen bei uns und
da hat die landesregierung einen beitrag
zu geleistet wenn man einfach die zahlen
vergleicht eine million für die studie
in bayern
65.000 für uns da sieht man die
größenordnung wo wir uns da bewegen mit
unserer stadt sagen würden sie mit blick
auf diese vergangenen wochen erstreckt
würden sie etwas anders gemacht haben
heute einige apps pr-agentur ja
eigentlich eigentlich würde ich hätte
ich nichts anderes gemacht weil wir
haben uns wirklich in einer ethischen
schwierigen situation befunden in dem
wir uns interessanterweise jetzt auch
wieder ein bisschen befinden
wir haben wissen generiert und wollten
es mitteilen
gleichzeitig auch vielleicht wenn man
das mal so sagt bei darüber wird gar
nicht so viel gesprochen wir waren die
ersten die im kreis heinsberg den
geruchs und geschmacks verlust
geschrieben haben und das ist
mittlerweile in den richtlinien in den
guidelines zum testen in vielen ländern
mit aufgenommen worden viele berichten
dass jetzt auch hörverlust und andere
ähnliche
symptome der korona viruserkrankung aber
wir haben das damals über die presse
kommuniziert und wir warten immer noch
im übrigen dass unser paper angenommen
wird ist es immer noch nicht angenommen
worden wir haben es eigentlich selber
ins fleisch damit geschnitten weil wir
nicht das hoch veröffentlichen können
mehr was jetzt allgemeinwissen geworden
ist zusätzlich hätten wir es natürlich
auf dem pre print server stellen können
nicht was er ja auch gefordert wird aber
für solche kurzmitteilungen gibt es
keine treppen server und wir können es
können nur große artikel hochgeladen
werden
und jetzt waren wir im zwischenbericht
500 teilnehmer hatten wir unser ergebnis
das konnten wir nicht irgendwo hochladen
werden warten können dann würden wir
aber bis jetzt warten mit den argumenten
und wahrscheinlich bis nächste woche
warten bis wir dann das manuskript
fertig haben aber ich bin jetzt sitze
ich wieder hier auch sehr entspannt im
übrigen weil wir ja die
zwischenergebnisse gezeigt haben sonst
wäre ich nicht entspannt werden die
jetzt sehr anders und sie haben im
grunde eine bestätigung bekommen sowohl
für die immunität die in heinsberg
ungefähr bei 15 prozent liegt als auch
für die letalität die sie bei helfen sie
mir 0,375 gesehen haben also wir wollten
nicht über die endergebnisse reden aber
ich sage ich bin mal entspannt feiern
wird das sind die zahlen die wir vorher
beschrieben haben und wir kommen dann
können natürlich sehr viel mehr jetzt
analysieren wir können sowohl unabhängig
ist ja ein protokoll der
weltgesundheitsorganisation wir haben
uns das nicht ausgedacht was ja auch so
im raum stand sondern das von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation vorgegebenes
protokoll das ja auch nächste woche dort
vorstellen werden
unsere ergebnisse wir haben haushalte
analysiert und einzelne personen und wir
haben dadurch die möglichkeit sowohl zu
sagen wie es denn die übertragung
zwischen in den haushalten gibt es mehr
infizierte kinder oder mehr infizierte
großeltern wie es die übertragung
nachdem lockdown gewesen oder ist das
alles nur auf der kappensitzung passiert
und diese fragen wie können wir jetzt
gerade beantworten und haben wir für uns
schon beantwortet und darum war so eine
studie extrem wichtig
die letalität kann man vielleicht sogar
auch auf ganz deutschland übertragen
stichwort haushalt ist jetzt aber noch
einmal interessant da gab es auch eine
studie aus island das mit jedem
zusätzlichen menschen in einem haus land
ein 15 prozentiges höheres risiko
besteht ermittelten sie das auch
ungefähr so sie müssen nicht alles sagen
ja wie gesagt ich wollte ja die
endergebnisse noch nicht reden aber ich
will island genau
ich finde das eine sehr gute annahme
dieser oder sehr gutes studie die dann
die ist dann übrigens durchgeführt wurde
und auch in china wurden die 15 prozent
beschrieben wo jetzt auch die frage für
uns ja auch eigentlich erstmal
überraschend dass es nur eine
15-prozentige erhöhung der chance gibt
sich im haushalt zu infizieren
ob dass sie das jetzt mit den kindern
zusammen hängt da kann ich noch nichts
zu sagen kinder sind am aller
schwierigsten einzuschätzen auch wenn
kinder die eltern investieren viel wie
das stand der wissenschaft sich hierfür
auch verändert hat ich meine die
grundannahme früher bei den kindern war
dass die hauptüberträger sind obwohl
selber milde symptome
jetzt gibt es ja neueste
forschungsergebnisse die das ein
bisschen relativieren
das zeigt doch dass ein wissenschaftler
die bislang in der nische gearbeitet
haben durch die krise ist dass auf
einmal das thema das uns 24 stunden
sieben tage die woche beschäftigt
wissenschaft arbeitet wissenschaftlich
mit these antithese und dann gibt es
möglicherweise eine synthese was wir
jetzt aber gerade machen das aus den
politiker zu machen
das ist ein bisschen das problem also
wenn man diese sphären voneinander
trennt sind auf dem richtigen bild bei
den ergebnissen geblieben frage nach
frankfurt zu
wie wichtig messi ist immer zu
unterscheiden zwischen der
wissenschaftlichen arbeit zwischen einer
solchen studie oder 50 anderen studien
in deutschland und den interpretationen
also ich weiß von der veröffentlichung
der zwischenergebnisse heinsberg studie
in einem ganz anderen punkt irritiert
denn ich habe keinen grund
professor strikt nicht zu glauben dass
diese zwischenergebnisse und auch die
endergebnisse
einwandfrei sind also das wäre ja auch
bald veröffentlichen es wird ja auch
ordentlich geprüft habe ich keinen grund
zur annahme dass irgendwas nicht stimmt
und nicht interessiert jetzt auch
weniger die ganze pr-geschichte also ich
hab nur in diesen zwischenergebnissen
die haben sie auch auf der
pressekonferenz vorgestellt und auch
schriftlich veröffentlicht ich sehe
darin kein zusammenhang zu den
hygienemaßnahmen für die sie stehen doch
kein zusammenhang zu der stellungnahme
der hygieniker die sie jetzt auch noch
mal erwähnt haben auch in der sendung
noch mal das mag wahrscheinlich ihre
persönliche einschätzung sein aber ich
sehe da keinen zusammenhang zu ihren
daten aus heinsberg oder über sehe ich
da etwas
also da ist noch mal die frage ob und
warum sie denken dass wir waghalsiger
sein können und ein bisschen lockerer
sein können das habe ich nicht gesagt
waghalsige und lockerer als glaube ich
kann eine gefallen aber ich glaube was
was haben wir auf der pressekonferenz
die ergebnisse vorgestellt und haben
anschließend gesagt dass man dass die
hygienemaßnahmen das entscheidende sind
und haben auf die stellungnahme
verwiesen und wenn sie sagen das sind
zwei völlig unabhängige punkte
dann hätten sie das auch deutlicher klar
machen müssen denn ich glaube in
deutschland ist angekommen
diese zwischenergebnisse sagen uns
machen uns hoffnungen auflockerungen
ja das ist ein bisschen vereinfacht
dargestellt was wir da gezeigt haben
also um das noch mal zu umreißen es
sitzt ja nicht ich der dasteht und die
studie versinnbildlicht ich bin da ein
bisschen das gesicht geworden aber das
ein riesen team dahinter dass allen
voran professor hartmann der
leibniz-preisträger ist und genau weiß
was er wenn er über immunologe geredet
worüber er redet und dass professor
exner als leiter also direktor der
des instituts für hygiene dabei der auch
bei hygiene weniger ihnen das wasser
reichen kann also ich glaube er ist
deutschlandweit bekannt als einer der
großen hygieniker wir haben sehr genau
und sehr bedacht
dieses paper oder diese diese zwei
seiten dort zusammen geschrieben
das war nicht einer von uns alleine
sondern es war unser team im grunde
waren das über 80 menschen die daran
beteiligt gewesen sind und wenn man mich
kritisiert kritisiert man die aller art
dann auch mit die der ist wir sehen wir
haben zusammenhang zur hygiene den sehen
wir auch sehr klar in der studie
wir haben das vielleicht in den zwei
seiten nicht so raus gearbeitet aber es
gab auch im übrigen ein vorgespräch an
einem dienstag wo wir zwei stunden lang
fragen zu dem protokoll erklärt haben
die vielleicht nicht alle mitgenommen
haben und nicht nicht gesehen haben wie
wir das protokoll auf gesetzt haben und
wie wir zu den ergebnissen kommen aber
das war am dienstag vorher gelaufen
damit war das aus dem donnerstag bei der
pressekonferenz
also dann noch mal die eine frage würden
sie sagen all das was sie wissen und was
ihn raus jetzt eine genaue zusammenhang
zwischen ergebnissen und der weil ich
gerade fragen was war der genaue
zusammenhang und können wir also mutiger
sein als schon irgendwie das ich bin ein
bisschen verzögert tut mir leid
wir sind heute richtig immer ständig
rein quatschen wo war der direkte
zusammenhang zu den hygienemaßnahmen und
würden sie sagen wir könnten eigentlich
noch ein bisschen mutiger sein
ich habe nie gesagt man könnte noch ein
bisschen mutiger sein
was hier gesagt auch eine frage genau wo
wir den zusammenhang sehen ist einmal
der der stärke der symptomatik und der
hygiene
das ist auch sehr bekannt aus anderen
viralen erkrankungen
das sind sehr interessante publikationen
früher gelaufen von greta wo freiwillige
sich haben mit grippe infizieren lassen
mit aufsteigender dosis von grippeviren
und je schwerer ist die symptomatik
gesehen ähnliche zusammenhänge und die
einen daumen habe ich vorhin auch darauf
hingedeutet dass hygienemaßnahmen die
infektions dosis die viren dosis die
viruslast die man ab gerecht herunter
setzt
und da ist der zusammenhang mit der
hygiene und im übrigen auch der sehen
wir diesen zusammenhang in den
infektionsketten gut dann würde ich
musste mir fragen wollen
sie sind an kurven 19 selber erkrankt im
märz macht das den blick auf die politik
und auch die entscheidungen anders wenn
man eine solche persönliche erfahrung
hat also erst mal hat es einen bezug zu
der debatte von gerade eben nämlich zu
dem zeitpunkt als sich erkrankt war und
die symptome hatte die atypisch waren
sehr mild verlaufen sind gott sei dank
ist ja nicht jedem vergönnt war die
einschätzung der ärzte oder dem
mediziner das ist quasi nicht nicht
symptomatisch also kein test notwendig
und erst nachdem ich dann später gesehen
habe dass sich leute getroffen hatte die
positiv getestet worden sind habe ich
den test bekommen und bin dann auch
positiv getestet worden
das will ich damit sagen die
erkenntnisse ändern sich ständig wir
wissen sie natürlich sehr viel als
wissenschaftler als gesamtgesellschaft
wir wissen relativ wenig die
erkenntnisse verändern sich ständig das
sollte ein etwas demütig sein mit
demütig machen mit umfassenden aussagen
über das was in der zukunft passiert ich
bin da zumindest für meine person sehr
zurückhaltend ist erst das zweite ist
ich habe alles das natürlich mitgekriegt
was jeder normale mensch eben jetzt auch
mit krieg wie das ist mit häuslicher
quarantäne
wenn man eben home office hat und auf
einmal feststellt der vorteil an der
arbeit im büro ist du bist irgendwann zu
ende und dann bist du zuhause home
office wann ist das eigentlich zu ende
oder wenn du zwei kinder in die schule
gehen und jetzt zu hause sind und du
merkst erstmal dass wir fast
entwicklungsland sind bei der
digitalisierung von schulen sowieso was
das eigentlich heißt finnland die haben
das problem nicht die baltischen staaten
haben das land nicht die haben
rechtzeitig streitbaren internet gesetzt
die haben rechtzeitig darauf gesetzt
dass digitalisierung nicht verboten ist
dass man das auch in der schule anwenden
kann
wir halt nicht das merkmal jetzt ist
natürlich die kinder aus benachteiligten
familien besonders betroffen gerade
drohen da wirklich massen auf kinder zu
verlieren
das kosten schweinegeld später das
wieder gutzumachen
das merke ich gerade auch ich hatte ja
auch mal so einen kleinen mini ko in der
sendung bei den kollegen von ihnen als
das kind dann reinkam und sagte jetzt
rächt
jetzt will ich papa wieder haben also da
wird man schon sehr demütig und merkt es
gibt ein paar lehren also es gibt ja
auch leute die sagen das ist toll für
die gesellschaft wir lernen da so viel
das halte ich für wirklich absoluten
blödsinn
das macht mich richtig wütend ich habe
eine mutter die es 1933 geboren ich kann
dem nichts gutes abgewinnen
aber es gibt ein paar lehren diese
beibehalten für danach dazu gehört wie
wir miteinander umgehen also die
hilfsbereitschaft auch gerne bleiben
dazu gehört das haben sie alles gesagt
mit hygiene dazu gehört aber auch die
digitalisierung muss in diesem land
bitteschön anders werden die
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf muss
anders werden
die wertschätzung für bestimmte berufe
bitte nicht nur in sonntagsreden die
pflegerin die leute in den
krankenhäusern das darf gerne auch
danach alles so bleiben und sie auch in
form von bezahlung in form von
arbeitszeit etc umgesetzt